une robe de cuir comme un fuseau corit
du chien sans le faire exprès et dedans
comme un
matelot une fille qui tanganaelle
anglais C extra am mi blous qui chante
la nuit comme un satin de blanc marié
et dans le port de cette nuit une fille
qui tangue et vient
mouiller cet
extra cet
extra c'est
extra des cheveux qui tombent comme le
soir et de la musique bas des
reins ce jazz qui jazz dans le noir et
ce mal qui nous fait du
bien cet extra c'estes mains qui jouent
de
l'arc-en-ciel sur la guitare de la vie
et puis ces cris qui montent au ciel
comme une cigarette qui
prie cet extra
c'est
extra c'est
extra cet
extra des bas qui tiennent au perché
comme les cordes d'un violon et cette
chair qui vient troubler l'arché qui
coule ma
chanson
C extra et sous le voile à peine clos
cette TFF de noir Jésus qui
ruiss dans un berceau comme un nageur
qu'on n'attend
plus c'est
extra c'est
extra C extra
oui c'est extra
[Musique]
une robe de cuir comme un
oubli cor du chien sans faire exprès et
dedans comme un matin gris une fille qui
Tang qui se
ta C extra les blous qui sen balance
c'est li qui ne veut plus rien dire et
dans la musique
du silence une fille qui trongue et
vient
mourir C extra
ou C
extra C
extra c'est
[Musique]
exat merci